[energetic string music] ♪
Maile Harris>>
For that brief interval of a song
the entire world just melts away
and that is what always brings me back
[music continues] ♪
Nick Deluca>>
Coming into Yale
I knew there was a Yale Ballroom team,
I emailed over the summer
I showed up to the first few lessons
and from there it's
pretty much been my
main activity here on campus
As soon as I started dancing with
some of the senior members of the team
I knew that those were the people
I wanted to spend the next four years with
[upbeat samba music] ♪
Maile>> There are about 40
members on the team
we're an entirely student run
organization
we don't have any professional faculty
or any sort of advisor on our team
It's all student run.
"So you want me to step out?"
Nick>> In August to about September
that's mostly just practice
Maile>> That's really a time for all of us
to learn from each other
"yeah, that works!"
When someone doesn't know
how to do something
we always know we can go to each other
to be each other's teachers and coaches
"5,6,7,8... 1,2...!"
There's a huge balancing act that we all try
to juggle as we're going through training
you know you've got a full day of classes
and coming home at the end of the day
you really are exhausted so it's the
question of
why continue? Why do one more thing
that pushes you further?
"Ok, one more time..."
It's because there's something in you
that connects to the music
there's something in you
that connects to another person
and that is what helps you drive
yourself forward in everything else
when you get to refresh
yourself through dance
[slow ballad music] ♪
Nick>> In other sports that I've done
I never get the sense that I can stop thinking
but when we dance typically I don't
remember anything else besides us dancing
[passionate dance music] ♪
[audience cheers]
Nick>>
It's also something that we provide
to the Yale community that they
can all enjoy
and something new and something that's
not really focused on anymore
Maile>> You exist entirely in that moment
with the people that you are
creating with and storytelling with
That reinforces the kind of community and kind of bond that we share off the dance floor
because we take off our dance shoes
we put on street shoes
we don't stop being partners
Maile>> For the love of dance
Nick>> For the love of dance
[music ends] ♪
[clapping]